en el comunicado emitido por la
cancillería venezolana se denuncia un
supuesto plan para agredir a la
delegación que encabezaría Nicolás
maduro y perturbar el desarrollo de la
séptima cumbre de la comunidad de
Estados latinoamericanos y caribeños que
se desarrolla en Argentina por esta
razón anuncian que no asistiría al
presidente Nicolás maduro y en
sustitución en verían al canciller
venezolano Iván Gil recordemos además
que maduro ha limitado sus viajes al
exterior desde el año 2020 cuando
Estados Unidos anunció una recompensa de
15 millones de dólares por su captura
tras ser acusado de narcotráfico y
lavado de dinero ya se habían registrado
el fin de semana protestas en Argentina
por la posible presencia de Nicolás
maduro esto por parte de venezolanos
residentes en Argentina y también por
organizaciones defensoras de Derechos
Humanos incluso la ex ministra de
seguridad bajo el gobierno de macri
había advertido que pediría a la DEA la
captura de Nicolás maduro una vez
arribara a Buenos Aires este lunes el
mandatario venezolano participó en
movilización en rechazo a las sanciones
impuestas por Estados Unidos y Europa a
Venezuela y Desde allí anunció que
respaldaba la propuesta de los países
Argentina y Brasil de crear una moneda
común recordemos que ya este proyecto lo
había propuesto el fallecido presidente
Hugo Chávez en el año 2007